皆さんこんにちは
はじめしゃちょーです
以前僕のサブチャンネルの方で
クラッシュオブキングスのテレビCMにちなんだ
ドッキリを仕掛けるということで
視聴者さんの方に参加の募集をかけたのですが
その時
そのドッキリを仕掛けるターゲットの方がすごい大物のタレントさんというお話をしました
その大物タレントとは誰か
なんと
トミックさんです！
クラッシュオブキングスというゲームはですね
兵士を使って城を皆で襲撃するゲームなんですけども
どうもですねトミックさんのこの顎の部分が城に見えてしまいまして
ちょっと襲撃したくなってしまいました
今回はトミックさんの顎を城に見立てて
実際のゲームのように
城に襲撃してみたいと思います
というわけで今回ゲームをダウンロードしてくれた方の中から
１５人！優秀な兵士をこちらから選抜させていただきました
沢山の方の応募本当にありがとうございます
この後城が僕の家に泊まりに来るんですけども
城が寝静まった瞬間に
僕以外の１５人の兵士が
僕の家に来て
城を囲んで
一斉に城を襲撃してやろうと思います
トミックさんの顎に
いや城と言ってもやっぱり顎なので
分かりやすいようにシールを貼りまして
襲撃して行こうと思います
確実に城を討ち取ります
では行こう
本日は
お集まりいただき　ありがとうございます
今回の企画は
僕の家に一つの城が眠っておりまして
そのお城を皆で
襲撃しようという企画でございます
大物のゲストの方にドッキリする企画だったと思うんですけども
そのゲストの方はなんと
トミックさんでございます
爆笑
寝てるトミックさんを
襲撃しようというドッキリでございます
お願いします
v(´・ω・｀)v
ミッションスタート
早朝に別規格の撮影があると偽の説明をして僕の家に寝てもらっています
w(´・ω・｀)w
y(´・ω・｀)y
u(´・ω・｀)u
( ^)o(^ )
まずはアゴに城のシールを貼ります
🏰（城）
ぐっすり寝ていますね
m(´・ω・｀)m
難しい
t(´・ω・｀)t
起きちゃった
ｗｗｗｗｗｗ
トミック：え？
wwwwww
トミック：うぇい　うぇーうぇうぇい
精神的に不安定なトロール
失敗したけど寝かして再度挑戦
はじめ：ちょっと寝ててください
はじめ：とりあえずまだ見ちゃダメですよ
はじめ：待っててくださいね
トロールが空気を読まなかったため再び出撃準備に入る
(-。-)y-゜゜゜
トミック：何これ？
トミック：いい包丁だなぁ
城を襲撃しに来ました
トミック：何が？
ていう寝起きドッキリでした
トミックさんの顎を城に見立てて
大量の兵士が襲い掛かるドッキリ
トミック：は？ウソ　これ？
というわけでドッキリ大成功（？）でーす
お疲れ様でした！！！
トミック：撮影これじゃないでしょ？
終了です
（物足りないよはじめ君）
いつかリベンジ
はいというわけでドッキリ終了いたしました
お疲れ様でした
というわけで、途中トミックさんの顎に城を貼ったところでちょっと気づかれて
一回失敗っぽくなっちゃったんですけども
トミック：まだまだだな
皆さんに聞いてみましょう
はじめ：どうでしたか？
女性：悔しかった...
気づかれたんですけども
無理矢理寝かせて
次に繋げられたのでまあそこは良かったと思います
はじめ：どうでしたか？
男性：面白かったです！！！
男性：外から声聞こえた時ビックリしましたｗ
城を襲撃するのはこれほど大変なことだということが分かりました
クラッシュオブキングスでは簡単に城を落とせるので是非皆さん遊んでみてください
というわけでクラッシュオブキングス皆さんもうプレイしましたでしょうか？
このゲームは全世界で9000万ダウンロードを突破した城育成シミュレーションRPGでございます
本当に面白いので是非皆さん下からダウンロードできますのでプレイして遊んでみてください
じゃあな
完